if you're looking for ways to always do
what you want realize your visions and
ignore the haters then this video is for
you nothing gives me an adrenaline rush
like coming up with an idea I've never
worried when I was trying to be a pop
star and no money I never moaned about I
never borrowed money it was it was my
lot I chose to do that and then I've
always done things that were I wanted it
reputation is everything and I realize
it's not reputation is what strangers
think of you right and who you really
are is what your friends and family
think of you and they stay forever so I
just don't care now need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation
what's up it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out into the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew on today's lessons from a
man who wanted to study biology growing
up to becoming a comedian and actor and
at one point the third most influential
person in British culture he's Ricky
Gervais and here's my take on his top
tendrils of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one also my personal favorite in
this video always do what you want
Bob didn't said a man can consider
himself a success if he gets hit in the
morning goes to bed at night and in
between that's exactly what he wants and
I've always done that I've always done
that I've never worried when I was
trying to be a pop star and no money I
never moaned about I never borrowed
money it was it was my luck I chose to
do that and then I've always done things
that were I wanted it rule number two is
realize your visions nothing gives me an
adrenaline rush like coming up with an
idea
honestly I I can't sleep and if I think
of it before I go to bed I've got a
worker over so I don't forget it when I
wake up and that's a that's a lovely
thing to wake up to oh that idea right
you know and it doesn't get any better
than when it's in your head really it
and then you just gotta ruin it as
little as possible honestly when I first
started this I thought I was a writer
right and I probably only directed
because I realized that I could protect
the writing and then I produced to
protect the directing right so it's it's
all to protect the idea everything that
and I play that guy because I know how
to do that guy in my head right and you
can't play everyone or Peter Sellers
good but I know I can but you know I
mean yeah so it's it's it's and I'm
afraid it's trying to realize the vision
with with 60 other people right that's
that that's the challenge rule number
three is learn by doing what advice
would you have to aspiring comedians
stage time is everything you can you can
write and write and write and it could
be pretty funny and they can laugh but
if you do the stage time yeah it's it's
actually doing it I I can't think of an
analogy there's nothing like it
other than okay you could you could
learn about making pots on a pot as well
in theory you could learn if you can
watch YouTube is you could
an expert and until you put your hands
on it you know these are you know I
think that's it you've got it's stage
time and our stage time is worth 50
hours writing if you if you haven't done
it yet its stage time it's just doing it
doing it you know and if you can do it
if you could do it every night you know
you might be you might be getting and it
depends what you mean by good do you
mean good you're good and it works every
night to 15 people or do you mean I'm
good because I'm making money now and
I'm famous and everyone loves me
I mean de la Souris yeah well then
there's a whole lot of luck as well then
my okay is my advice work hard and be
lucky but I just think I think you have
a passion for it you've got have a voice
you got to find your voice how old do
you 23 see you 23 right you're young
handsome what do you want to be a
comedian for cue rule number four is
don't focus on the money
I've never craved money I've never been
proud of money per se in fact the first
few years of getting a newfound wealth I
felt guilty about it and I still feel a
little bit it'll be on it because there
was a nobility in in poverty really and
and so I've always thought that if I'm
gonna be rich and famous then I've got
to be proud of how I made my money and
how I got my fame and making money
making money I've never understood it
do you know I've never understood it I
don't play those games I don't play that
I don't try and make more money I never
I've never tried to make money rule
number five is create for yourself when
we discussing things like Oh what what
the audience expect or what do they want
don't you just simmer in me that says I
don't care it's not up to them it's not
them I'll do exactly what I want and
that you know then you can't if you if
you didn't like it I I don't care don't
come and see me again don't ever come
and see me I don't want to be judged I
really don't want to be judged I don't
charge anything that I wouldn't want to
do or has ever done to find an audience
I do what I do and somewhere in the
world there's enough people that want to
come and feel that venue absolutely
that's exactly right it's like Darwinist
really because you have your thing that
you do and then people flock to it and
if you don't if they don't they don't
know the exact night rule number six is
fill your days with fun turning to
yourself rather than any character
you've written or played do you feel
fulfilled with what you're doing today
is there some other big challenge or big
project you'd like to take on give you
more fulfillment I don't
I've never I've just always got up in
the morning and wanted to fill the day
with as much fun as possible you know I
suppose that's everything I've done is
sort of slightly existential as well and
from the office it's about you know
people becoming 14 are they doing the
right thing Derek it was about people at
the end of their life what what can they
pass on even my children but flanimals
was about the sort of futility of life
and nature and ironic deaths and I don't
know why that is really I think it's
funny
I think it's funny life I think is it's
it's amusing because we take everything
so seriously we care about everything
passionately we have fights Wars worry
about little things and then we die and
the zephyr and there's nothing it was
pointless pointless we would turn we
return to the stars so I've always
thought I want to fill my days with fun
rule number seven is ignore the haters I
feared Fame when I want to stress
started doing this and it came I came to
it light and almost accidentally and I
suppose organically I got a little radio
job when I was about 37 38 after I'd
worked in an office for 10 years and
then I started popping up and then it
sort of grew from now but a little bit
on a thing called the eleven o'clock
show and and then the office came but I
knew I knew if I was I know a famous
actor or comedian that I'd be you know
recognised but I want to know that was
an upshot of it I wasn't doing it to be
famous and I sort of feared it I didn't
sign that I didn't sign that contract
you know with the devil make me famous
and you can go through my bins and do
not I mean right and I sort of worried I
think I worried about it because I
thought oh you know they say how all the
things about famous people and well you
don't you don't want to have horrible
things said about you and now it's like
water off a duck's back because it's you
know I mean it happens all the time
Twitter and which
reading every toilet war in the world at
once right and you shouldn't you should
know those things about you you know you
shouldn't hear things about you in a
normal life you shouldn't be famous it's
not to be famous and I sort of feared
that and for the first few years I
thought oh that's not fair because I
thought reputation is everything and now
I realize it's not reputation is what
strangers think of you right and who you
really are is what your friends and
family think of you and they stay
forever so I just don't care now and the
other one I take you to get that car
well it wasn't confidence
it was ambulation it was realization it
was a observational you know the first
bad review I thought oh my god no oh no
I'm still alive do not I mean right and
then here more and more anything and
people say oh I didn't like that and I
want to go I'm not giving the money back
you know it's it's all so subjective
that the only real thing is is what you
what you do with it rule number eight is
connect with your audience probably the
biggest single influence on my creative
process was something my old English
teacher said to me when I was about 13
or 14
he just said write about what you know I
usually wrote about things that I saw on
telly you know when we ever had to write
a story it was about a maverick cop or
you know a cowboy I always thought my
stories were the best they were more
exciting and whenever I first story and
handed it in I always got it back too
melodramatic write about what you know
and this was frustrating cause I was
thinking it's either good or it isn't
you know and I thought my stories were
so who who wouldn't like a story called
jezic about a maverick cop who didn't
play by the rules what he mad sumit this
could be on telly in fact I'm sure it
was and all the other kids were getting
B's and is writing about what they did
and then one day I just got fed up so I
thought I could teach him a lesson
and I tried to do the most boring story
in the world
my mum used to go on
neighbor's house she was an elderly lady
in a inner 80s and my mom would go
around you know everyday and clean up do
a bit shop in and cook her a meal and
sometimes I'd go around there and sort
of watch because I was bored and it's
it's not an exciting thing for a 13 year
old boy to watch his mouth clean up
after an old lady that isn't my idea of
fun so I thought I'll write a story
about that that is so boring and I wrote
in every detail I thought I was being
really clever going them we went round
we came in there was that there was a
smell of tea and lavender and mold and
my mum first I had to clean the floor
the old lady says sir if you eat and the
old lady said I haven't eaten today no
and I did it all when I thought I was
being so funny and getting my own back
on this teacher and I handed it in and I
thought that I show him and you know the
next day he'd marked him or when he was
looking on the hand denial and he don't
mind and he just saw at me that night
and I opened it up I and I looked at him
and he just went and it was the proudest
moment of my life
it sort of taught me that being honest
is what counts trying to make the
ordinary extraordinary is so much better
than starting with the extraordinary
because it doesn't really connect you
watch those sort of shows and it washes
over you don't think about it the next
day
whereas if something is real for one
person it's touched their life you know
and I think it's a creator and a
director it's your job to make an
audience as excited and fascinated about
a subject as you are and and real life
does that rule number nine is provoke
fight you're not afraid of dividing
opinion you're not afraid of you know
some people saying I disagree with you
and some people say I agree with you is
that something that's become more the
case as you've gone on your career and
you've been more successful well again
it
if everyone's agreeing with you you're
in an echo chamber you you've just
chosen you've just chosen your people to
speak to I mean the important thing for
me is that everyone's everyone no one
has to laugh I in fact I embrace the
gasps as much as the laughs because that
means that we're listening you know I
think it's a an offense is good offense
makes people think it makes them think
it makes them come up with it another
argument you've got to come up with an
argument because I'm just tired of
people saying I'm offended I want to say
so what that just means you're just
telling me your feelings I've got a pain
in my knee
what do we do about it and rule number
ten the last one before the bonuses is
perform amazingly my favourite war is oh
so many
like oh good
Oh Falklands that's probably the
Falklands because some we won that one
and uh it was great it was against
Argentina yeah weird go to war without
its leader
oh I okay fair enough yeah
the reason it's my favourite war is that
it was a range war and what that means
is the Argentine guns could fire nine
kilometres the British guns could fire
17 kilometres so we just parked our
ships ten kilometres away and there's
worth falling into the sea and we were
shelling the SH out of them it's the war
equivalent of holding a [ __ ] at arm's
length
is flighty you're just kicking with
Ebola
Vietnam best soundtrack
second mobile best ending I had to be
the end that was a great finale you
couldn't follow that good yeah so I put
rule number one always do what you want
is my personal favorite I just really
like that definition I think that's what
we want to do as entrepreneurs we want
to start a business to be able to live
the life that we want to be able to
create the impact that we want and not
every day is perfect and amazing and
roses and everything goes according to
plan there's a lot of crap you have to
deal with as an entrepreneur but we're
trying to build something better and
net-net I love my life I love my
schedule I get to dictate it I get to
decide to make youtube videos for you
guys I get to decide to invest in the
companies that I do I love the work that
I do on a daily basis and it's all
within my control and so I love that
definition of success and I think as
entrepreneurs is something that we're
all striving for to really create the
world and create the ideal days that we
want consistently every day that's why
we left our jobs to go and do our own
business so rule number one is my
personal favorite I love to know do you
agree with me
Israel number one the best in this video
or was the one that struck you harder
that had a bigger impact on you I'd love
to hear from you if you share it there
are the comments below
now I made this video because Jimmy
don't jump ask me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in the
description to the request line and you
can go and cast your vote I also want to
give a quick shout out to beat Gerber
thank you so much man for picking up a
copy of my new book the top ten rules of
success and posting that awesome picture
online I really appreciate the support
man and I hope you're enjoying the book
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
so it is music your enemy disband
there's the thing in the movie where
they play to no one and that happened to
me I played a little gig in about 1986
in a pub called the pullin gate and we
were up there and we did the soundcheck
and the guy said you might as well stay
on you're on now lads and I said when
they opening the doors and he said
they're open no one's come through to
see you and in real life I went ok let's
just do it like the best treat like a
free rehearsal and we just played eight
songs to no one do you have a special
place where you're right well I've got
I've got an office in my house and I've
got an office near my house and they've
probably seen less writing than me on
planes or trains or weren't going for a
run you know I I rarely sit down to
decide to write something it just sort
of comes and I've always you know and I
rarely write things down putting a stand
up I'd do it in my head I go for a run
and I come back and I love like the
little idea I tell Jane it she says
please don't do that in public
and I know it's good you've hosted award
shows you've won awards yourself what
advice do you give to people in order to
give a good speech don't take it too
seriously
remember no one cares about that award
as much as you do and don't cry it's
pathetic seriously and don't thank your
family they've done nothing or God same
reason that always gets me so many
people thank God for an award okay it's
the one reason I'm I sort of when I
hosted the Golden Globes at the end I
said and thank God for making me an
atheist that was just I just want you to
redress the balance good with all those
people that got that win the Lord and
they cry and they say thank God thank if
you believe in an all-powerful
interventionist God right who presumably
either causes or doesn't stop famine and
earthquakes you'll thank but he's got
time for you to win best music editing
in a variety special
come on just go Cheers
it's a bit of metal don't take yourself
too seriously
ah say thank you takes a bit funny the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon pay believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]